vient alors fait assez exceptionnel
michel drucker vous avez pu rencontrer
de biophysique était passe à rignac
influenceurs oui oui il ya quelques
heures vous avez pu faire une interview
avec lui et alors on a parlé de ce film
rêve ou réalité fils un peu obsession
mais on a aussi parlé de la comédie du
cinéma italien
je vous propose d'ailleurs de retrouver
dino risi sur les bords de la seine
c'était hier que commencer toute
l'affairé est en amour d'abord une
histoire d'amour oui qui se passe entre
un homme et une femme qui est morte ou
et c'est vrai métier
givi parce que parce que l'amour de deux
matches elle a fait la faire vivre parce
que l'amour qu'elle a pour lui la sphère
l'a fait aussi
vivre c'est un peu oui c'est vraiment de
la nouveauté j'ai eu trois fils dino
risi avec fantôme d'amour on est
vraiment beaucoup plus proche de votre
film âmes perdues ou dernier amour que
de que des monstres et peu et que du
fanfaron
depuis quelques années il semble que que
le temps que la province que le
vieillissement et que la mort soit des
thèmes qui vous passionne plus comment
vous expliquez ça c'est votre évolution
à vous inscrire peut-être je me à broche
ça me fait même mais rend évidemment
intéressant ce thème mais c'était aussi
pour pour changer un peu
enfin il y a
merci de la comédie italienne a fait
même trop maintenant tout le monde le
fait
à 15h j'essaye enfin de lire des livres
qui qui me font en sortir un peu dessus
jana est-ce que vous avez l'impression
également que le public
on a peut-être un peu assez de ce type
de comédie que vous avez beaucoup pms
que ça correspond également un
changement de goût du public à votre
avis oui je crois que le lui car narcy
est une peu fatigué ça
on a eu trop de ce nom du swing et ton
de ses acteurs et
évidemment ça la comédie c'est un genre
qui ne peut pas mourir oui mais doit
elle doit elle doit changer de camp ça
de oui et en italie déjà ça soit une
fois on fait encore des combinés ont
fait la commune il ya des jeunes qui
sortent de nos comiques qui est enfin
donnée
nouveauté un peu de fraîcheur à cette
comédie que nous resservir
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
votre complice de toujours que ce soit
fini a dit que ce soit à marcello
mastroianni ou gassman on convient
également de faire autre chose parce que
je parle de ces acteurs cas on peut voir
parler de rithy sans parler d'eux vous
êtes très lié depuis des années tout
sourire il a même bien oui évidemment
main et il faudrait en fait aussi
d'autres choses parce que mais ça ça
on est toujours le cinéma du julier aa
reste des questions financières n'étions
de machines gain de 2
c'est le public enfant qui décide si
l'acteur tient alors il continue à faire
un film assez rugby assez alors il faut
j'en fais un truc qui qu'il trouve une
autre route dino risi si vous deviez
citer deux ou trois des films que vous
avez réalisé et qui sont les plus
importants pour vous il y aurait une
comédie de comédie où il y aura un film
plutôt dramatique
je crois qu'il y à quelques comédies qui
sent qu'ils ont un tout petit peu
enfants font drame
comme c'est pas une vie difficile aux
vient de fanfarons et les monstres
parfum de femme a dans sa classe le film
complet 5 mais il yad'autres aussi des
petits films même qui est qui on n'a pas
très bien marché mais que j'aime
beaucoup comme moi même un enfant un peu
de ce malade